acababa de salir de una condena de 20
meses de cárcel por su participación en
el movimiento prodemocrático de 2019
pero vuelve a prisión por 5 años y nueve
meses Jimmy light fundador en Hong Kong
del periódico Apple Daily fue declarado
culpable de dos cargos de fraude en
octubre acusado de subarrendar el
espacio de sus oficinas a una empresa de
consultoría que operó a Puerta cerrada
durante dos décadas lo que supone un
incumplimiento de los contratos de
arrendamiento firmados por el rotativo
con una empresa gubernamental el
tribunal de distrito impuso a ley una
multa de más de 256 mil dólares
estadounidenses y le prohibió dirigir
empresas durante ocho años suco acusado
One también fue sentenciado pero a 21
meses Este es el último de una serie de
casos contra activistas Pro democráticos
que según los críticos es represión
contra disidentes de alto perfil en otro
caso contra lay El Magnate de los medios
de comunicación podría ser condenado a
cadena perpetua si es declarado culpable
en el juicio por delitos contra la
seguridad nacional que se celebrará el
13 de diciembre durante años su
periódico Pro democrático Apple Daily ha
criticado abiertamente al partido
comunista chino pero finalmente fue
clausurado en virtud de la ley de
seguridad Nacional de Beijing tras la
detención de sus Editores y periodistas
el pasado año los procesos judiciales
contra Jimmy light han suscitado
preocupación por la libertad de prensa
en Hong Kong y han empujado a jóvenes
profesionales de la prensa a trasladarse
al extranjero